[Música]
hola buenas tardes quiero platicar con
ustedes acerca de un concepto colonias
chinas construyendo desde lo colectivo y
podemos definir este aspecto como un
concepto subjetivo y cuando digo su
objetivo es que hablamos de lo que se
piensa se dice o se ve cuando se
transita un espacio público o cuando se
pasa o se vive en un conjunto
habitacional o en una manzana con alta
densidad o componentes con poca densidad
de vivienda
hicimos una pequeña encuesta para
preguntarle precisamente a las personas
sobre qué es lo que ellos piensan cuando
les ponemos de frente el concepto de
colonias chinas al final de cuentas como
les decía es un concepto subjetivo y
tenemos que contemplar cuál es el
pensamiento de las personas cuando leen
está esta frase compuesta colonias
chinas qué es lo que piensas que es lo
que es lo que pasa por tu cabeza sería
un error tratar de definir un concepto
con palabras que de antemano significan
otra cosa entonces ese es ese es el
primer parte de ahuano y recibimos esto
como respuesta decidimos varias
respuestas pero pues obviamente
concentramos los que son sinónimos y
tenemos esto no siento miedo en eso para
mí es una colonia ácida un lugar donde
no siento miedo donde me siento seguro
donde puedo caminar libremente donde
siento confianza donde vivo en armonía
un lugar donde muchas cosas se
construyen en conjunto donde hay
la iluminación creo que aquí va de la
mano el hecho de sentir seguridad y el
de poder caminar con gran libertad por
las banquetas o por las calles una
colonia chida es aquella que tiene
espacios asignados para áreas áreas
verdes y aquí bastante interesante que
en un principio no se nos hubiera
ocurrido o hubiéramos pensado que
hubiera sido parte de los resultados en
la encuesta es una colonia china es
aquella que tenga buenas paradas de
camión con sombra hablando del clima
aquí en nuevo laredo pues tanto en frío
como en calor creo que es bastante
importante y va está bastante
interesante tener un buen espacio donde
esperar al transporte del transporte
urbano partiendo de ahí podemos resumir
que todas estas definiciones o lo que la
gente piensa que es una colonia chida
hablamos a grandes rasgos de que
hablamos de espacios más caminables y
allí englobamos iluminación banquetas
pues obviamente más anchas buena
señalización banquetas que no están
obstruidas
la propia señalización pero también que
no están obstruidas por los botes de
basura o
vehículos estacionados encima de la
banqueta hablamos de compromiso de
gobierno y compromiso de los ciudadanos
y también una colonia china es aquella
que nos otorga y nos brinda experiencias
positivas si tratamos de que también
todo el discurso manejarlo siempre de
manera positiva de que no es una corona
chida sino más bien que es una colonia
china porque es allá hacia allá debe de
ir
el sentido de la conversación y tratar
de construir siempre sobre como si se
deben hacer las cosas y olvidar el como
como no se deben hacer las cosas
ahora unos planteamientos que también
queríamos hacerlos como ciudadanos y que
también ponemos sobre la mesa y se los
comparto a ustedes lo tanto para que
respondan sino para que los hagan
propios los reflexionen y los piensen
cómo es que ustedes definen hoy día en
este momento a un lugar como habitable
que lo hace un lugar más habitable o
menos habitable un lugar una colonia
comparada una con otra que lo hace más
habitable el ancho de sus calles la
iluminación el ancho de las banquetas
que tenga áreas verdes sobre las
respuestas que arrojaron anteriormente
la que les mostré anteriormente de las
encuestas cuáles esos aspectos son
prioridad para ustedes si la densidad me
refiero a cuántas casas hay por manzana
cuántas personas viven en cada casa que
lo hacen más o menos habitable algún
sector
y la otra es como colocan ustedes las
etiquetas de ese colonia ese sector ese
barrio es seguro como las colocan que
que utilizan ustedes o qué factores
utilizan ustedes para definir esto no
sabes qué es un sector limpio ahí hay
etiquetas que son de acuerdo a la
sensación etiquetas que son de acuerdo a
lo que vemos y otras son de acuerdo a
nuestra posición ubicación geográfica
como la de cercanía como defines un
lugar un recinto una papelería un
restaurante está cerca o no está cerca
y este pues obviamente es también una
cuestión física y que también es visible
como lo cómo lo vas a etiquetar un lugar
por tiene áreas verdes o no tiene áreas
verdes empezamos a definir un poco ya
aquí en este punto que es un espacio
público
ahora todo esto no es solamente algo que
surge de
del instinto por mera curiosidad si
surge de ello pero tratamos siempre
obviamente de aplicarlo o de utilizar
una lista de conceptos formales yo desde
la profesión como arquitecto desde la
trayectoria participando en proyectos
sociales y dentro de los mismos habiendo
tenido la oportunidad de recorrer muchas
ciudades de latinoamérica
decíamos sabes en aquel viaje nos la
pasamos también estuvo muy chido el
viaje porque porque parte de la
experiencia no era tanto haber salido de
antro no era haber haber agarrado a la
jarra no era haber estado mucho en playa
sino que muchos de esos viajes se
convirtieron en viajes testigos porque
pudiste experimentar la cultura la forma
de vivir si pudiste vivir más convivir
como un ciudadano más de esa ciudad la
ciudad te arropó entonces
que permite que una ciudad logre que
unos extranjeros sientan se sientan
parte de sí cuando hablamos de
amityville de habitabilidad urbana
hablamos principalmente de dos factores
la ergonomía la ergonomía de las
personas y el confort algunas algunos
conceptos hablan de la situación del
clima que tanto se lamentó hoy en los
árboles las sombras te permiten el ancho
de las calles hablamos de cuestiones
físicas como ya comentamos algunas pero
por otro por otra parte también hablamos
de cuestiones de contaminación
saneamiento drenaje también los aromas
afectan si vives a un lado de un arroyo
pues probablemente hay la habitabilidad
aunque tengas las calles más anchas y
mucha área verde quizá el aroma te
afecta no el hecho de que vivas al
costado de las vías del tren pues puedes
tener cumplir con muchos de los factores
por el sonido es muy estruendoso
entonces afecta y se ve reducido el
indicador de habitabilidad urbana
muchos de estos conceptos como les digo
son dados sí pero son más los que son
creados y a partir de aquí a partir de
aquí damos en caemos en cuenta en que
entonces como muchos son creados los
podemos modificar o empezar a crear los
de una manera distinta a partir de ahí
nos empoderamos y podemos levantar la
mano y decidir por aquí por acá no de
esta forma de este tamaño en este
sentido con esta altura así con este
confort acústico les hablaba de que
estos son los entes
a través de los cuales se pueden
transformar los espacios públicos el
primero son las organizaciones de la
sociedad civil junto con gobierno si
ellos se encargan de la asignación de
los recursos de la definición diseño y
ejecución de las políticas públicas
asimismo también hablamos de la
incidencia debe haber una vinculación y
una estrecha colaboración entre la
sociedad civil y el gobierno
por otro lado hablamos de la iniciativa
privada que yo yo busco dentro del
sistema privado dos aspectos una que
inviertan en lo social y dos que tengan
un compromiso moral constante que
busquen devolver algo a la sociedad de
la cual se sirven y la tercera
un poquito más a ras de piso en un
contexto o en un entorno mucho más
cercano hablo de los vecinos de los
vecinos que tienen sus casas ahí en esa
colonia en ese barrio si ellos que no
son parte de una agrupación que es lo
que pueden hacer ellos si de eso se
trata está esta charla qué es lo que
pueden hacer y es que lo que puedo hacer
yo y ustedes como parte de una colonia
de una cuadra vamos a ponernos de
acuerdo con los de con los vecinos de al
lado
de la esquina de en contraesquina los
que están antes de la tienda para ver
nosotros qué es lo que podemos hacer
antes de ser una organización de la
sociedad civil obviamente empezamos a
generar pequeños grupos en donde los
intereses son los mismos son compartidos
y así mismo debe ser la obligación debe
ser compartida
tenemos tres principales herramientas
para poder transformar los espacios el
juego la convivencia y la prevención del
crimen a través del diseño del entorno
el tercero es una herramienta un poco
más formal pero bueno los dos primeros
el juego muchas de las veces
desestimamos el juego como una
herramienta de transformación pero el
juego es una herramienta universal de
cambio porque a través de ella se
generan esquemas formales para el uso de
los espacios públicos desde la profesión
nos tocó a un lugar alguna vez echar a
andar una cancha de pasto sintético para
fútbol y hablábamos con los
representantes de gobierno sobre
precisamente la importancia del juego y
de dotar de este espacio de un uso
formal para que después de la entrega se
pudiera utilizar de una manera constante
con un esquema y con un programa para
que no sucediera precisamente lo que
sucedió al poco tiempo el espacio estaba
vandalizado porque porque no había una
forma ya específica de utilizar el
espacio al final de cuentas y aquí en el
juego pues obviamente pueden participar
niños hombres mujeres adultos jóvenes
entre semana en fines de semana en la
mañana tarde y noche el juego es una
herramienta bastante flexible que nos
permite lograr una transformación
pacífica e ir entrando poco a poco la
convivencia
si se vuelve un hábito también puede ser
una herramienta poderosa si el hecho de
vamos a poner de acuerdo y vamos a jugar
bingo vamos a jugar lotería o una
cascarita entre los vecinos o entre
todos vamos a sembrar me gusta mucho el
ejercicio y creo que aquí por el sector
aquí por el bulevar está la colonia de
liste y frente al un arroyo creo que es
el arroyo del coyote
existe un tramo grande de jardines que
es mantenido por los propios vecinos y
yo creo que es un jardín a la altura de
muchos de los que están en zonas
residenciales entonces eso precisamente
hace la convivencia no es un juego es
una convivencia en donde todos comparten
porque el espacio no es de uno o de otro
el espacio al final de cuentas es de
todos y aquí en la prevención del crimen
a través del diseño del entorno hablamos
precisamente la altura de los arbustos
que como una guía rápida no deben
rebasar la altura de la cintura de que
la copa de los árboles debe iniciar a la
altura de la cabeza para que
precisamente cuando pase alguien sea
visible de adentro hacia afuera no
colocar botes de basura o elementos
físicos que permitan el escalamiento
entren a tu vivienda etcétera etcétera
etcétera cuando no estás de todo esto a
una pequeña comunidad les das
herramientas precisamente para que
puedan transformar su espacio y puedan
evolucionar poco a poco y así el espacio
al final de cuentas logra tener una
identidad los vecinos tienen una
identidad y con mucho orgullo dicen yo
soy de de tal ciudad de tal barrio de
tal calle de tal número de cuadras yo
soy de la 23 por así decirlo si se logra
desarrollar el concepto de empatía y
tolerancia al enterarte un poco más de
los estilos de vida de las formas de
vida ahora así como que dicen de lo que
trae en el morral cada quien logra
desarrollar los conceptos de empatía y
de tolerancia
la sensación de seguridad crece porque
también al tener identidad al ser más
empático y más tolerante yo cuido yo
vigilo yo protejo yo participo
y por ende se cierra el círculo con el
incremento en la calidad de vida
como un mensaje
final la arquitectura
el urbanismo y es un consejo para los
colegas para los desarrolladores de
vivienda
la arquitectura y el urbanismo son
disciplinas que deben ser utilizadas
para liberarnos que deben ser utilizadas
para satisfacer las necesidades de quien
las habitan y dentro de esas necesidades
están las de ser parte de si están las
necesidades de convivencia o de
socializar no debemos restringir estas
dinámicas a recintos en específico no
restringir las tareas de socializar o de
convivir a la escuela a los lugares de
trabajo a los antros a los restaurantes
oa los bares las colonias las calles las
banquetas son para eso
nuestra tarea al final del día es ocupar
los espacios hacer los nuestros porque
el espacio como les decía no es tuyo no
es mío es de todos gracias
[Aplausos]